Ich glaube, ich lasse meine Jacke an. Ich würde euch das auch empfehlen. Das ist schon ziemlich frisch. Ich glaube, wir haben ja auch gar keine Form von Heizbarkeit. Deswegen will ich eigentlich keine Jacke anziehen, weil ich... Weil du deine neuen Pulli zeigen möchtest. Ich möchte mich da souveräner fühlen. Dunkelgrün, interessant. Letztens hast du mir mal deine Farbpalette erzählt für deine Kleidung. Hauen wir schon, sonst mache ich keinen Gag. Und es war... wir laufen auch schon, ja. Okay. Du hast mir gesagt, deine Farbpalette ist eigentlich braun. Modisch, wie ist es in Richtung herzliche. Nein, überhaupt nicht. Hast du nicht zugehört? Also meine Farb... Ich habe eine Farbpalette. Wenn man in meinen Kleiderspann guckt, kann man es aufmachen. So wie bei den Simpsons, dass immer ein Outfit da hängt. Nein, bei mir ist es ein bisschen anders. Ich habe Farbpaletten, Grau, also Hosen sind oft Grau, Schwarz, Dunkelgrün und als Akzentfarben Bordeaux Rot. Wenn ihr mal darauf achtet, ich trage entweder Schwarz, Grau, Grün oder Bordeaux-Rot, und jetzt ist grün kalt neu dazugekommen, weil ich dachte, komm 2018, wag mal eine neue Farbe. Aber Akzentfarbe hört sich dann so an, als würdest du das quasi zu den anderen Farben dazutragen. Ja, ist vielleicht das falsche Wort. Einfach. Was? Was ist das überhaupt für eine Stimme, die man hier vernimmt? Hä? Hä? Ach so. Hallo? Ist das jemand? Es war ein Tag, wie jeder andere als Stefan und Florentin auf einmal eine seltsam aussehende Person neben sich sitzen sah. Hörst du das auch, die Stimme? Ja, ich höre die Stimme. Wer kann das sein? Ich sag mal, hallo und herzlich willkommen zur neuen Ausgabe des Podcast-Ufos. Lange musst du dir warten, aber wir sind heute wieder live dabei. Es ist die erste Ausgabe 2018. Frohes neues Jahr. Und falls ihr denkt, wir machen jetzt so eine läppsche, na, wie bist du reingekommen, na, was ist passiert, wie viele Raketen hast du abgefeuert, nein, wir haben einen fantastischen Gast uns eingeladen. Denn wir dachten, wir starten das Jahr 2018 mit einem von euch, weil ich meine, das ist das Jahr der Community, auch bei den Chinesen ist das Jahr der Community, deswegen dachten wir, wir laden den Reichsten einen von euch, den, der sich erkauft hat, bei uns zu sein. Bei Patreon haben wir damals wahrscheinlich den Fehler gemacht, dass wir die Incentives nicht so ganz so ernst genommen haben. Und bei 300 Dollar ist es, glaube ich, Patreon-Geld, könnt ihr hier zu Gast sein. Und du hast es gemacht, du hast 300 Dollar gezahlt, damit du heute hier sein kannst, im Podcast Ufer in Folge 100. Ist das zwar irgendwas? Ja, ich habe auch extra für die Folge bezahlt. Das war auch ja so abgibt. Ja, ist die. Herzlich willkommen, Nico. Hallo, Nico. Nico? Ja, Nico. Richtig, ja, ja. Cool. Und ihr seid jetzt wer nochmal? Stefan. Und? Ah, sehr gut, dass wir das mal sagen. Florentin will ich, dass wir das. Nach so einem Namensschild, weil normalerweise sagt man das ja immer so am Anfang.
Ja, mein Name ist Stefan.
Wenn jemand reinkommt, der den Podcast noch nie gehört hat, dann wisst ihr ja gar nicht, wer ihr seid, sondern nur wer ich bin und ich bin ja nicht der Star, also außer heute. Kleine Frage, woher hast du 300 Dollar? Ähm, ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Kein Dollar, dass es diese andere Währung ist, das klingt noch ominöser irgendwie. Ja, also die 300 Dollar, die ich war im August für einen Monat in Australien, nein, Quatsch, also ich war wirklich im August für einen Monat in Australien, aber da habe ich natürlich nicht die 300 Dollar her, weil ich habe ja schon, glaube ich, ungefähr vorher bezahlt, ich weiß es nicht, ist schon was länger her, also das Podcast-Suche ist jetzt nicht bekannt für die beste und schnellste Planung oder Rückantwort. Das gebe ich an den Community-Manager Stefan Tietze weiter. Alles klar, habe ich mir direkt notiert. Auch, dass die Beleidigung in Minute zwei erfolgt, finde ich auch spannend, die erste. Aber dafür bin ich ja da, also um die kritische Stimme der Community an euch anzunehmen. Das hast du falsch verstanden, du bist da, um uns zu loben. Ach so, ach so, ja, also dann... Ich habe mir aufge... Wir nehmen das nochmal auf, das war ja jetzt gerade nur ein Testlauf. Ne, wo hast du das Geld her? Ich brauche Finanztipps. 2018 ist bei mir bis jetzt noch nicht finanziell noch nicht so gut gelaufen, sag ich mal. Es gab ein paar Fehlinvestitionen. Dennoch habe ich eine Menge Geld verloren bis jetzt. Man muss sagen, Florian, die musste seinen Schlüssel auch abgeben mittlerweile. Er hat keine E-Mail-Adresse, die wurde heute gekappt, sein Slack-Account wurde ihm gekappt. Du bist arbeitslos, du bist jetzt die gewaltige Power der Arbeitslosigkeit. Ich bin arbeitslos, die Steuer sitzt mir im Nacken und mein Nachbar guckt mich immer so merkwürdig an durchs Fenster. Ich glaube, der plant schon irgendwas. 2018 wird, glaube ich, nicht mein Jahr. Es gibt ja viele, die sagen, 2018 wird mein Jahr, 2018 wird definitiv nicht mein Jahr. Das kann auch nur das Jahr von einem werden. Also die Chance ist 1 zu 7 Milliarden. Wessen Jahr war 2017? Meins. Deins tatsächlich? Oder Nikos. Wo hast du 300 Euro her? Dollarverzeihung. also das liegt grössteilend tatsächlich daran, dass ich einfach ungefähr null Ausgaben habe. Also ich wohne nicht allein, ich wohne auch bei meinen Eltern. Und daher, ja, also die grössten Ausgaben... Du siehst nicht wie jemand aus, der bei seinen Eltern wohnt. Es ist der Bart, glaube ich. Bart ist so selbstbewusst, ich glaube nicht, dass du bei den Eltern wohnst. So bin ich. Also ich habe so, wie so ein Maler, Ich hab quasi über so eine ganz alte und hässliche und dreckige Leinwand was drüber gemalt, was schön und selbstbewusst aussieht, aber eigentlich bin ich noch der Typ, der zu Hause wohnt und ungefähr 30 Prozent seines Lebens nur ausserhalb der Tür verbringt. Ich hab folgende Theorie aufgestellt eigentlich, bevor du heute hergekommen bist. Du bist eins von drei Möglichkeiten. Also jemand, der sich einkauft im Podcast, ist entweder ein Creep, Anmöglichkeit A, du könntest gleich eine auswählen, Antwortmöglichkeit B, ein Vollidiot, oder Antwortmöglichkeit C, jemand, der hier was verkaufen will oder irgend so eine Propaganda machen will für irgendwas. Reich habe ich nicht aufgeschrieben, weil ich zähle Reich zu Vollidiot. Ja, okay, also ich würde sagen, es ist A bis C. Creep. Ja, also A bis alles zusammen. Also ich bin ein Vollidiot-Creep. Und ich habe für euch auch heute dabei den neuen Speckweg 3000. Ach was? Ja. Ach, man merkt es ja an, du bist sehr gut gebaut, muss man dazu sagen. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Das habe ich nur dem Speckweg 3000 zu verdanken. Der ist jetzt seit Dezember auf dem Markt. Und na ja, wie der Name schon sagt, der Speck geht weg. Wie? Das ist ein Erfolgsgeheimnis, dafür müsst ihr den jetzt kaufen, aber wie man an mir sieht, es funktioniert. Es funktioniert wirklich. Fantastisch. Deswegen wackelst du auch schon die ganze Zeit so. Das ist ja die Saison im Hintergrund. Man muss den durchgehen tragen. Es gibt ja diese Vorher-Nachher-Models dann immer im Fitnessstudio und sowas. Ja, vor allem, wann wurde dieses Foto gemacht? Weil ich meine, du musst dich ja dann dazu entscheiden, Model zu werden, bevor du gut aussiehst. Oder ist jeder, der sagt, okay, ab morgen Model, ich mache jetzt schon mal ein Foto um diese Vorher-Nachher-Dienst. Weil ich glaube, Vorher-Nachher-Models verdienen locker dreimal so viel wie normale Models, weil das einfach seltener ist. Du musst dich zu einem wertvollen Model machen. Du musst was haben, was nur ganz wenige haben. Ich glaube zum Beispiel, dass Übergewichtmodel ein durchaus lukrativer Job ist. Der Finger war generell gen Himmel gerichtet für eine Ansage. Aber im Himmel ist er immer Richtung Stefan. Das ist richtig, weil ich so groß bin. Und das Jahr 2018 geht mir. Herzlich willkommen hier seit dem Podcast Ufo Gold,ig hier in 2018 gelandet. Du siehst, hast eine fantastische Figur, wo hast du die? Fitnessstudio oder ...? Ja, also fast. Also ich spiele sehr viele Videospiele und gucke YouTube und sitze aber auf meinem Bett. Aber du guckst dann so ein Tutorials bei YouTube. Du sitzt auf deinem Bett. Ach so, ja, ich habe ... ja, weil mein Bett ist quasi gegen die Wand und an dem Fussel meines Bettes ist mein Fernseher. Problem, du kannst dich nicht anlehnen, das Anlehnenproblem, entweder du gehst so weit zurück, entweder ist dein Bett mit Kopfteil an der Wand oder mit Seite an die Wand. Mit dem Kopfteil an der Wand, aber das ist, du sprichst es an, man könnte ja eigentlich denken, ach ja, mit dem Kopfteil an der Wand, dann rückt man einfach mit dem Gesäss so weit zurück, dass man quasi an der Wand lehnt. Oh, okay. Ich habe quasi keinen Bettkasten, sondern mein Bett ist eigentlich nur eine Matratze auf Stelzen. Es wird immer wehren. Ja, aber es wird noch schlimmer, weil mein Kopfteil steht an einer Schrägen, an einer Dachschrägen. Das heißt, mein Bett ist so, es ist jetzt nicht so perfekt für den Podcast. Moment, aber die Dachschräge geht doch nach innen.. Du hast gerade die Dachsträge nach außen gezeigt. Was ist das für ein Pilzhaus? Das ist oben nochmal so groß nach außen. Er wurde im Schlumpfenland. Ja, genau. Meine Eltern wollten halt einfach, dass oben der Platz ist. Das heißt, wenn du aufschreckst morgens, was mir ja immer so passiert, weil... Nein, okay, die Dachschräge hat jetzt keinen Winkel von 20 Grad. Das ist schon eine normale Dachschräge. Aber das Problem ist, ich kann mich trotzdem nicht anlehnen, weil wenn ich mich anlehne, dann kommt mein Kopf schon an die Dachschräge, während von meinem Rücken zur Wand noch ungefähr ein halber Meter Platz des Riss sehr unangenehm ist. Und ich glaube, daher habe ich auch meine höchst unergonomische, ich weiß nicht, ob das Wort so richtig ist, Körperhaltung. Aber die, stimmt, dieses Aufschrecken ist ein beliebtes Stil mit den Filmen. Wenn du so einen Albtraum hast, dann schreckt jemand auf. Ich glaube, es macht niemand. Ich würde mir aber auch die Frage stellen, wie würde die Szene wirken, wenn die Person dann nicht aufschreckt, sondern so ganz normal, so Augen auf und sich die Augen reiten. Einfach so krasser Albtraum, irgendwie seitdem die Freundin, der Kopf dreht sich um 180 Grad und du so, what, krass und dann so, cut, zu, bett. Ja, ich muss ... und dann ... Ich hatte einen Albtraum, Ron Weasley.
Aber dann ... ich hab auch, ich musste eine Szenen drehen für Gute Arbeit, wo ich in einem Kofferraum, Gute Arbeit war dieses Projekt, was letztes Jahr mal irgendwann so ein paar Leute erreicht hat, aber es war diese Szene, wo ich im Kofferraum lag, mit einem Gaggingball und ich dachte halt, dann hat mir der Regisseur gesagt, ja, da machen die den Kofferraum auf und dann wachst du auf von dem Licht. Erstmal frage ich mich, wer schläft ein, während er entführt wird mit einem Gaggingball im Mund und dann hinten der zusammengekauert in seinem Unterhemd in seinem Kofferraum liegt und dann dachte ich mir, habe ich gemerkt, dass es unfassbar schwierig ist, aufzuwachen und das gut zu spielen, weil du normalerweise in Filmen kennst es nur, dass du aufwachst, die Augen aufreißt, aufschreist, aber eigentlich wacht man so ganz entspannt auf und dann gähnt man doch so, das war echt unangenehm, das habe ich nicht gekriegt. Aber es ist doch so der, das habe ich gelernt, in Das Leben der anderen, über diesen Stasi-Film, dass die Schuldigen einschlafen, die Unschuldigen nicht. Wenn du jemanden verdächtigst, hey, du warst es, dann sperrst du den erst mal ein und dann guckst du, was passiert. Und der schuldig ist, der wird ruhig und schläft irgendwann ein. Der unschuldig ist, der bleibt wach, weil der Unschuldige ist ja in einer Stresssituation, der fühlt sich unfair behandelt, der sagt, fuck, wie komme ich hier wieder raus, oh mein Gott, wohin ging der Schuldige. Der ist natürlich auch in einer Stresssituation, aber der hat kein Geheimnis. Also natürlich sagt er es unschuldig, es ist ein Film, der hat einen Oscar geworden, verdammt nochmal, und ich muss hier nicht den rechtfertigen. Es ist auch so ein Ding, wo man dann die berühmte Donutplatte hinstellt in den Verhörraum und dann aber noch keinen Kommissar reingehen lässt. Und dann muss man darauf achten, ob der, der verhört wird, den Donut isst oder nicht. Und ich weiss nicht genau, wer schuldig ist. Das habe ich erlaubt. Der, der nichts isst, der ist schuldig, weil der ist sich ja zu unangenehm in der Situation, was dann natürlich wieder gegen das mit dem Unschuldigen, der nicht einschuldigt ist. Der unschuldig ist, ist. Der schuldig ist nicht. Aber er isst, würde ich so essen. Ich würde sagen, es ist ungerecht, dass ich hier bin, wenn ich unschuldig bin. Gott sei Dank habe ich wenigstens diese Donuts als Entschädigung, würde sie essen. Das ist mein Denken. Also der Unschuldige. Er isst schuldig einen Donut. Genau, er isst unschuldig einen Donut. Deswegen. Ich glaube, man kann für beides gute Argumente finden. Ich glaube, man kann sehr viele Argumente für Donuts finden. Ich glaube auch, für Donuts Essen auf jeden Fall.
Aber was ich mir gemerkt habe, ist, dass der, der schuldig ist,
der hat sich eine Lüge ... zurechtgelegt. So, ne? Florentin Wehe aus Ebersbach, leider die Werte nicht bestanden.
Der, der schuldig, der unschuldig. Ne, nochmal vor vorne. Wir hören den wild lebenden Vogel jetzt. Das ist ein... Mach Musik, mach Musik. Stimmt in die Regie, Panik. Was machen wir jetzt? Mach Musik! Warum sagt er gar nichts? Deswegen haben die auch immer acht Stunden überzogen, weil diese irgendwelche Leute Wetten machen, wo man die nicht kontrollieren kann. Was ich sagen will, ich will eins nach dem anderen. Ich will sagen, der, der lügt, hat sich eine Lüge zurechtgelegt und er wiederholt die immer Wort für Wort. Das heißt, wenn du dir sagst, ah, wo waren sie um zwölf Uhr, dann sagt er, ich war bei meiner Freundin und habe Fernsehen geschaut, und zwar Oprah. Wohingegen der, der, der, der nicht schuldig ist, der sagt, ja, ich war, der, der, also der wiederholt nicht immer dieselben Worte. Schaut euch einfach das Leben der anderen an, das ist ein guter Film. Leute, es ist, warum, warum mögt ihr meine Filmkritiken nicht, warum mögt ihr meine Filmkritiken nicht? Wenn du komplett in das Leben der anderen Merch gehüllt bist, auch Strange. Ja. Neues Outfit. Ich weiss auch nicht, warum du Kopfhörer von die Leben der anderen hast.
Es war dabei bei der DVD-Box. Das hab ich aber auch so noch nicht gesehen, ja. Gibt's Schindlers Liste-Merch? Gibt's eigentlich ... Wie sieht die Marketing-Erteilung von Schindlers Liste aus? Es gibt auch diese Bubbleheads mit dem roten Mädchen. Diese Funko-Pops. Aber im Ernst, du bist ... Gibt's auch Funko-Pop von den Glorious Bards, so ein Hitler mit so zerschossenem Gesicht. Das glaub ich schon. Das wär eigentlich ziemlich cool. Guck mal, das ist so eine Sketche-Idee. Hier, Jung von Max. Ja, komm nicht mit Sketche-Idee. Du kommst jetzt mit Sketche-Idee? Ich hab auch mit Sketche-Idee. Ein Jahr ... Na, forget it. Ja, okay. Du bist ein Jahr zu spät. Nee, hau raus. Nee, hau raus jetzt! Hau raus, du musst halt nur damit rechnen, dass es in Stephans Nachfolgeprojekt, Stephans verrückte Welt, in zwei Wochen auf Seite eins verwurzelt wird.
Verrückte Sketchwelt, Stephans mit der Arbeit.
Ja, also die Idee ist mir tatsächlich letztens beim Einkaufen gekommen. Ist immer wichtig dabei zu sagen, wo einem die Idee kam. Ja, natürlich, also ich habe das so in ganz vielen Podcasts und Videos und so weiter schon geschaut und gehört, also das macht man halt so. Ja. Und ich will ja professionell wirken. Und zwar, man ist an der Kassensituation, man ist an der Kasse und eine Person vor einem bezahlt gerade und dann kommt der Protagonist dran und bezahlt mit Karte. Und wenn man mit Karte zahlt, dann bekommt man ja immer diesen Wisch ausgehändigt, wie man da unterschreiben muss. Manchmal, aber auch random. Ja, ja, aber halt in dieser Situation. Ich glaube, die würfeln das aus, ob man unterschreiben muss oder die Passwort eintippen muss. Oder werfen eine Münze. Ja gucken sie so, als ob sie die Unterschriften vergleichen, das ist auch immer interessant. Ja, das klingt ja gar nicht. Aber auf jeden Fall bekommt man diesen Zettel, der ja ungefähr so lang ist wie mein Unterarm, aber den hat sich ja noch nie, also noch nie jemand durchgelesen. Und das war die Idee. Ah, der liest das durch. Der liest das komplett durch und alle, und dann hört man vielleicht noch so seine Gedanken, wie es so ganz laut, also laut im Kopf hüttet. Wenn man so einen Regisseur sagen, liest noch ein bisschen länger, liest noch ein bisschen länger, nicht schneller. Ja, und dass dann halt alle so genervt sind und dann die Pointe, also das ist eigentlich keine Pointe, aber das ja schon die Pointe ist, der Nächste ist dann dran, der sich schon die ganze Zeit abgefuckt hat, bekommt einen Zettel vorgelegt und liest auch alles. Liest auch! Finde ich gar nicht schlecht, finde ich tatsächlich gut.
Ohne Scheiss, ich hab noch ein paar.
Wir haben damals ein Autorencasting gemacht,
wo Leute Sketche einreichen mussten, und das war katastrophal.
Das wäre der beste Sketch gewesen.
Hands down, das sagst du jetzt nur, weil ich euch 300 Euro gegeben habe.
Ja.
Ganz kurz, habt ihr Lust, was zu trinken?
Tatsächlich schon.
Oder? Gerne.
Das war nicht sehr überzeugend. Hast du jetzt Lust, was trinken? Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob die Frage ernst gemeint ist. Doch, aber ich würde ja was besorgen jetzt so lange. Aber du willst was besorgen. Ja, also ich meine, wir sind ja jetzt auch erst gerade in Minute zwölf, oder? Ja, fünfzehn ungefähr. Ich dachte, hier wäre echt zu trinken im Raum eigentlich. Ich dachte, hier kann man jetzt irgendwo hingehen im Raum und dann was zu trinken besorgen. Das ist auch so, stelle ich mir Stefan als Gastgeber vor. Ein Gast kommt zu ihm und sagt dann und dann fragt er, hey, möchtest du was trinken? Ja, ich muss aber erst gucken und dann, ich hab gar nichts. Aber auch total unbeholfen. Ist Leitungswasser okay? Nee, Leitungswasser ist nicht okay. Leitungswasser ist nie okay. Ich hab neuerlich eine Werbung gesehen für diese Sodamaschinen. Und der Verkaufsgrund ist offensichtlich,
nicht schleppen zu müssen, wenn man grosse Kästen zu Wasser kauft. Ja, völlig obsolet jetzt, wo du dir Sachen liefern lassen kannst. Und dann kommt halt irgend so ein Rewe-Typ, der schleppt das Treppenhaus hoch. Ja, aber wir machen gute Sodawasser. Wir haben auch mit Cola-Geschmack. Kann ich nicht Cola kaufen? Diesen Himbeer gibt es nur bei uns. Also ich habe letztens für, ich sage jetzt nicht den Namen, aber für eine Matratzen. Hast du gerade WhatsApp aufgemacht? Ich erkläre, hey Stefan, Stefan, Stefan! Hey, er hat sich diese Zeit gekauft, er kann technisch gesehen wirklich machen, was er will. Ich halte es nur für unklug, dass jetzt WhatsApp... Nein, nein, nein, also ich erklär's gleich noch. Es ist nicht ... Es wird dir auch ... Es wird mega lustig, passt auch. Na, also und zwar von einer Matratzenfirma, die Matratzen herstellt, und die haben gesagt, man kann die Matratze für hundert Nächte testen und sie dann immer noch zurückgeben. Und da stand ausdrücklich, man kann in diesen hundert Nächten mit der Matratze machen, was man will. Mhm, rat mal. Also das war so eine leicht anzügliche Werbung. Ratet mal ganz kurz, bevor du weitersprichst, weil es passt genau dazu. Ratet mal, wer diese Matratze sich gekauft hat jetzt. Deine Mutter, dein Cousin. Ich habe mir diese Matratze. Ich fand es echt. Also es war nicht dieses Argument, was mich überzeugt hat, aber wir haben gesagt, Stiftung Warentest, die beste jemals getestete Matratze.
Und ich dachte mir, alle Betten der Hersteller, alle Matratzen der Hersteller müssen sagen, fuck, weil natürlich kaufen jetzt alle diese Matratze, die kostet 199 Euro.
Ganz kurz, aber deine Idee ist, dass man in den 100 Tagen dann auch andere Sachen macht. Also nee, das war so eine anzügliche Werbung, die haben gesagt, ach ja, man kann ja dann auch Sexhals, das wurde jetzt nicht ausschließlich gesagt,
ja, machen wir es mal.
Und ich denke dann so, und dann, was wird dann mit dieser Matratze gemacht, also wenn ich da reinblute und ich weiß nicht, was man sonst noch in der Matratze machen kann, was wird dann damit gemacht? Ja, das hast du doch vergessen, kein Mensch kann sich irgendwas hundert Tage lang merken, ich habe das probiert nicht. Kein Mensch, der, der, der, das ist halt genau, glaube ich, genau der Marketing-Trick, du baust halt auf Faulheit. Du baust darauf, dass sie das Treppenhof hochschleppen, reinlegen, allein das Tuch, Betttuch, würde mich davon abhalten, wenn ich sage, hey, wenn jemand vor meiner Tür steht und sagt, gib mir deine Matratze jetzt, ich gebe dir eine neue und du kriegst tausend Euro oben drauf, sage ich, nope, ich hab keinen Bock, mit diesem Scheiß Bettlaken da mich irgendwie darin einzuheddern und da vor allem während jemand zuschaut, das ist alles schlimmste, was es überhaupt gibt, während jemand zuschaut, ein Bett zu machen, weil da kann man ja nur versagen, du kannst ja nur scheitern. Das stimmt, das stimmt. Aber ich glaub auch nicht, dass die Tricks anwenden müssen, weil wie gesagt, das ist die beste jemals getestete Matratze. Okay, warte, heute ist der, warte, wir halten es mal ganz kurz fest. Heute ist der 16. Januar 2018. Kannst du mich bitte in 100 Tagen, ist mir noch ein paar abgelaufen, in 98 Tagen erinnern, dass ich jetzt noch die Möglichkeit habe, meine Matratze zurückzugeben? Ich möchte die Rockett, äh, Entschuldigung, die Podcast-Ufo-Community jetzt dazu aufrufen, Park is happening! jetzt dazu aufrufen, Stefan bitte in genau 98 Tagen eine Twitter-Nachricht oder eine Facebook-Nachricht zu schicken, dass er sich jetzt noch überlegen kann, die Matratze umzutauschen. Und ich bin mir hundertprozentig sicher, und ihr könnt jetzt auch gleich 40 Folgen nach vorne skippen, um zu sehen, ob es funktioniert hat. Ich bin mir hundertprozentig sicher, dass es zu dem Zeitpunkt komplett vergessen hat. Komplett vergessen hat. Er wird dann so denken, was wollen die alle? Und dann so bei der zehnten Nachricht, ach so, Florentin hat das damals gesagt. Dann hat er die Matratze aber schon seinen Eltern vorgestellt. Ich bin so gespannt, aber es ist ein interessantes Experiment, weil ich auch jetzt warte, wie viele Nachrichten überhaupt kommen, weil die es auch alle vergessen werden. Und außerdem ist deine Prämisse ja auch, dass, also ich glaube nicht, dass einen dieser Matratzenhersteller informiert, ach die hundert Tage sind übrigens vorbeigehen. Nein, natürlich nicht. Das ist ein Gewitz. Die sind ausgeschlafen vor allem. Vor zwei Tagen war es zu spät, müssen wir nicht sagen. Stimmt. Weil dann würde er natürlich denken, ja, dann ist ja der Beweis, dass er einmacht. Traue niemals Matratzenhersteller, die sind ausgeschlafen, die sind fit, egal mit wem du dich anlegst. Nicht mit Matratzenherstellern und nicht mit Energydrinkherstellern, du kannst nicht gewinnen. Die sind länger wach. Traue niemals einem Verkäufer bei Betten24 oder bei Matratzen Concorde mit Augenringen. Niemals. Das kann nicht. Gab es nicht mal so eine Talkshow, wo so eine Schlafforscherin, da war die mega verschlafen aussah, so mit dem Hahnblatt gedrückt. Weil sie nachts immer forschen muss. Aber das ist auch ein geiler Gag. Das wäre mein Ansatz gewesen tatsächlich, als du gesagt hast, hundert Nächte lang testen, war mein, mein Sketch Instinkt war, warum nicht hundert Nächte und hundert Tage, was passiert während den Tagen? Musst die Matratze in den Tagen zu ihrer Familie? Aber du hattest die bessere Sketch-Idee als ich. Deswegen hat er noch einen Job und du nicht. Vielleicht muss die Matratze auch während den Tagen auf die andere Seite der Erdkugel, wo dann Nacht ist, wo es dann andere Leute... Sehr gut, die reist um die Welt.
Genau, das wäre eigentlich eine coole Filmidee, die Matratze, die um die Welt reist.
Nein, nein, nicht so ganz okay.
Ich weiß nicht, man kann ja auch umdrehen, da hat man eine andere Liegehärte.
Ich kann nur diese Matratze jedem empfehlen, geht mal auf Bett eins oder so. Vor allem, also wie unfassbar verwirrend ist es denn bei der Matratzenherstellung, weil es gibt einmal Federn, Vögel haben Federn und es gibt
Vielen Dank. Also wie unfassbar verwirrend ist es denn bei der Matratzenherstellung, weil es gibt einmal Federn, Vögel haben Federn und es gibt Federn. Wir kommen zum Grundschul-Podcast. Vögel haben Federn. Und in der Herstellung so, ja und wie viele Federn sind jetzt in der Matratze? Stopp kurz, reden wir jetzt über Federn im Sinne von üüüü oder Federn im Sinne von worum geht's? Also da kommen diese sprachlichen Sachen zusammen und am Ende des Tages einfach alle hochrotter Kopf, ich raff gar nichts mehr, haben wir jetzt Federn oder Federn gebaut. Und deswegen sind alle Matratzen auch schlecht und deswegen ist auch, ist Chef Stiftung Warentest auch froh gewesen, einmal die eine gute Matratze getestet zu haben. Komm, die ist immer noch nicht gut, aber die ist die beste jemals getestet. Das ist genau wie diese eine Brücke, wo die eine Seite Zentimeter und die andere Seite Inch hatte. Und dann haben die sich in der Mitte getroffen und sind so 30 Meter und dann vorbeigefahren. Genauso ist es mit den Federn auch so. Am Ende bauen die einen ein Kopfkissen und dann sind die falschen Federn drin. In meiner Vorstellung fahren auch immer noch die Autos da einfach ins Meer. Die haben es auch nie korrigiert.
Wir waren bei SimCity, wo das dein Geld ausgeht, mit der Brücke zählte, denkst du ja, wir lassen es erst mal so und gucken, wie es funktioniert und dann bauen wir sie noch weiter.
Und irgendwann steht so ein kleines Ausrufezeichen irgendwo ein Bildschirm und man scrollt so rüber, fuck, habe ich vergessen noch.
Und unten sind die Haie schon. Ich finde auch gut die Vorstellung, die haben sich nicht getroffen, niemals, weil sie die einen Inch, die einen Zentimeter rechnen, aber die konnten das Problem auch nie korrigieren, weil die eine eine andere Sprache sprechen als die anderen, und auch da herrscht einfach Kommunikationspunkt.
Die einen sprechen Englisch und die anderen Amerikaner, die einen fahren Autos, die anderen Schiffe, es war ohnehin ein merkwürdiges Projekt.
Ja, aber lass dich nicht verunsichern, mach ruhig einfach in dieser Folge das, was du willst, einfach komplett, wenn wir nicht über die Dinge reden, über die du reden willst, musst du es sagen, weil wir sind dir alle schuldig. Ich meine, du hast 300 Dollar Schulden, ich meine, wir müssen irgendwie einen Weg finden, wie du langfristig wieder rauskommst. Tatsächlich, was ist das Gegenteil von Schulden haben? Also wenn jemand Schulden, gibt es dann für das war doch, ich kann ja nicht sagen, Gläubiger sein. Ja, Gläubiger sein. Gläubiger sein! Yes! Na ja, aber es ist kein Wort. Es ist halt eben, also ich würde sagen, ich bin Gläubiger mit so und so viel Geld, sage ich das dann, ich bin Gläubiger mit, die Summe ist ja egal, aber mit mehr als 300 Euro, weil mir noch zwei Personen Geld schulden, das heißt, das war eine gute Investition, weil ich weiß, ich krieg sowieso irgendwann vielleicht mal das Geld wieder, also wenn wir Kontakt wiederherstellen. Aber nee, ansonsten ja. Hast du... Bist du zufrieden mit der Antwort, Flo und die? Ich schaue mich sehr kritisch an, so, warum redet dieser Mensch so... Treuhand? Aber gibt es da nicht... Das sind diese finanzielle Wissen, dieses Pracht. So kannst du jeden verwirren. Dieses Federnproblem hatte ich selbst noch persönlich, weil ich mir eine Wee-Uwee-U-Feder kaufen wollte. Da haben wir das schon das Problem. Ist das jetzt der Vogel gewesen? Dün, dün, dün, dün, dün, dün, dün, dün. Ich sage das Wort Feder und ihr müsst sagen, was ich meine. Feder. Sowas war doch wirklich schon mal. Es war wirklich schon mal Film. Nein, wir haben mal. Das war nicht wirklich. Und ich weiß, wie wir noch, wo wir da aufgenommen haben. In dem Bandraum von Dendemann. Wirde Folge. War cool. Du wolltest eine I, I, I, Feder kaufen. Ja, genau. Und da ist mir eingefallen, dass ich dann, ich irgendjemand gefragt habe, ob er weiß, wo ich eine Feder herbekomme, und er meinte dann, welche Federn. Und dann bin ich zum ersten Mal draufgekommen, gibt es, es muss noch irgendein Wort für die Metallfeder geben.
Also man kann natürlich Metall und Vogelfeder sagen.
Warum wolltest du eine Feder haben?
Das ist jetzt irrelevant.
Welche Feder?
Wolltest du zum Mond?
Mit einer Feder?
Wolltest du zum Mond springen?
Wolltest du dein Trampolin reparieren?
Wollt ja jemand vom Dach und dann zum Mond springen.
Ich bin Herr über diese Folge.
Gut. Wir reden nicht mehr über den Mond. Hast du das verstanden, Florentin? Alles klar. Nicht mehr über den Mond. Äh, ja. Ich wollte mal ganz ein Mond-Thema. Okay, ja doch, ich habe nichts Besitzes. Die Kugelschreiber, die Feder, das war immer, die ist immer weg. Oh, so sich gekügt wie in der Geoingenieur. So geil einfach. Das war wie beim Zimtschnecke der innere Kern. Das war einfach so. Ja, ähnlich, nur komplett anders. Richtig, aber auch gleich. Und wenn das weg ist, dann bringt das Ganze nichts mehr. Ich fand die Zeit toll, wo man in der Schule angefangen hat, sich von Füller zu verabschieden und angefangen hat, mit Kugelschreiber zu schreiben. Aber das war auch die Zeit, wo man immer weniger Acht auf seine Schrift gegeben hat. Irgendwann war's einem scheißegal. Ich weiss doch wirklich, wie ich in der dritten und vierten Klasse dachte, ich will meine Schrift schöner machen. Und dann so mit der sechsten, siebten Klasse dachte ich so, ach, eigentlich hab ich da auch gar keinen Bock mehr drauf. Warum kriegt man überhaupt noch Schreibschrift beigebracht? Damit du wieder rauswachsen kannst. Was? Das ist ein Emanzipationsprojekt. Einfach damit du lernst es, damit du dann sagen kannst, ich leg den Füller weg, ich bin jetzt erwachsen, ich schreib wieder Druckschrift. Sag ich mal, kulturtheoretisch total genial. Warum lernt man dann nicht, dass alle Schwarzen furchtbare Menschen sind? Ja, im Ernst. Aber das würde ja dann heißen, dass zum Beispiel, meine Eltern schreiben zum Beispiel noch in Schreibschrift und nicht in Druckschrift, oder zumindest sehr schreibschriftig, dass sie sich weniger emanzipiert haben als ich in dieser Hinsicht, weil ich bin wieder zurück zu, naja, Druckschrift können wir es nicht nennen, aber sowas in der Art, und meine Eltern schreiben noch Schreibschrift. Gibt es irgendwann einen Punkt? Eigentlich jeder so ab 40. Können Chinesen in Schreibschrift schreiben? Ich glaube schon, ich glaube tatsächlich, dass es da unterschiedliche Arten gibt. Das frage ich mich jedes Mal. Es gibt auch dieses traditionelle Chinesisch, also bei Google-Übersetzer gibt es traditionelles Chinesisch. Und einfach. Ich glaube, es heißt wirklich einfaches Chinesisch und dann noch ... Wie im Bundestag. ... Mandala, genau. Im Bundestag kannst du dir auch einfaches Deutsch, kannst du dir die Seite ja auch angucken. Die ganzen Beamtenseiten kann man sich auch einfach im Deutsch, für Leute, nicht gut Deutsch sprechen. Nee, das ist kein Scherz. Also ich habe gerade Steuerprobleme, massive Steuerprobleme. Auf den Finanzamtsseiten steht auch immer einfache Sprache. Also Leute mehr in Folgen einkaufen. Ich habe noch nicht draufgeklickt, weil ich mir so ich kann Deutsch. Aber irgendwann teilweise ist es wirklich komplizierte Thematik und man denkt sich, ja, ich probier's mal. Aber wie ist es dann einfach, also ist die, ist mehr Schrift da drauf, soll heißen, erklären die Dinge genauer oder erklären die Dinge einfacher? Es sind kürzere Sätze und weniger komplizierte Satzstrukturen, aber dadurch mehr. Aber die wollen ja die gleichen Dinge erklären. Ja, ja, aber warum? Ist es denn quasi genauso, ich denke mal, dass da irgendwelche offiziellen Formulare oder ähnliches dann umgeschrieben werden wahrscheinlich, oder irgendwelche offiziellen Regeln oder was weiß ich. Formulare weiss ich nicht, aber es ist halt zum Beispiel, ich habe jetzt kein konkretes Beispiel, das Beispiel sowas, bevor sie x, müssen sie y, wird zu erstens x, dann y. Also diese bevor grammatikalische Strukturen,uren, die jetzt nicht so ganz einfach zu verstehen sind. An solchen Stellen frage ich mich dann immer, ist das in irgendeiner Weise vom Sinn beziehungsweise von der Wertung her anders? Also ist ein hochdeutscher oder wie heißt es kompliziert deutscher Text wesentlich mehr Wert als ein einfacher deutscher Text? Weil warum steht dann nicht einfach alles in einfachen Worten? Ja, aber ich glaube, du wirst ja völlig wahnsinnig, wenn du immer solche drei Wortsätze hast. Ja, aber auch, ja, naja, wir sind das Finanzamt, wir kümmern uns um Geld, das geht an den Staat, damit der Staat das machen kann. Ich finde auch gut, wenn die... So, und das ist ja, da kannst du ja auch ein bisschen... Wenn die Alternativen unten jemand anklicken kann, kompliziertes Deutsch und einfaches Deutsch wären, da würde ich auch auf einfaches Deutsch gehen, aber es ist normales Deutsch. Es ist nämlich wie bei Pages, wenn man eine PDF exportiert, hat man die Wahl zwischen den Qualitätsstufen hoch, besser und optimal. Wo ich mir sagen muss, es ist genial, weil ich habe immer ein gutes Gefühl. Ich meine, hoch ist nicht, du kannst die Bilder, die Bilder sind ja immer verschwommen und so, aber ich denke, das ist doch gut, das ist doch eine hohe Qualität. Das ist einfach richtig gut gemacht. Tolle Idee. Das ist wirklich seltsam, vor allem weil in meinem Gedankenkonstrukt kommt auch hoch nach besser. Ja, weiss ich. Also, ne, also hoch ... Ja, das ist so wie hyper, mega, ultra. Ja, eigentlich nicht, weil hoch und besser sind ja Worte, die existieren. Also, hyper und so auch. Ja, also soweit ich weiß schon. Ich habe gestern erst nachgeschaut. Ah, okay. Letztes Jahr. Ja, aber besser ist immer besser, als egal was. Du kannst immer sagen, immer einmal mehr. Ja, aber besser ist immer das Besser. Mit optimal in der Reihe. Hoch, besser, optimal. Das ist ja das Problem. Aber für mich steht trotzdem hoch über besser, weil es so, ach komm, weil es halt hoch ist. Kurz noch mal zu chinesischen Schriftzeichen. Ich frag mich immer, haben die ... Ich dachte, jetzt recherchiert. Gibt es mehr Schrift ... also Fonds, Fonds, nicht Fonds, aber Fonds bei Pages zum Beispiel. In dem normalen, was haben wir, arabische Schriftbild? Einmal Schriftarten. Genau, haben wir sehr viele Schriftarten. Haben die chinesischen Leute, haben die ähnlich viele Schriftarten? Weil ichelle mir vor, du kannst ja die Zeichen ... Ja, stimmt. Man kann die minimal verändern und schon ist was anderes. Aber auf der anderen Seite ... Es sind Zeichen, es sind immer noch maximal komplizierte Zeichen. Aber auf der anderen Seite gibt es ja auch irgendwelche Schriftarten oder Fonts, die quasi ... wo dann Buchstaben total anders aussehen. Also ein N kann in einer Schreibschrift Font wie ein M aussehen. Und daher würde ich sagen, dass es ähnlich viele Fonts geben könnte. Das ist so doof mit Font und Font. Ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass man gewisse Fonts designtechnisch übertragen kann, aber du hast ja zum Beispiel keine Serifen in den chinesischen Schriftzeilen. Vor allem, es werden dann sehr viele sehr viele Serifen. Oder? Nee, Serifen hat nicht mit Schreibschrift zu tun, sondern das hat einfach ein Lesbarker. Ja, ich weiß ja, aber ich meine, das wäre ja dann, ich meine nicht, dass das wie Schreibschrift ist, sondern einfach... Du meinst das Richtige. Genau, ich meine das Richtige auch. Ach so, ich meine das Falsche. Ach sorry, jetzt habe ich. Nee, also ich meine quasi, dass wenn es im ... Ich sag jetzt Deutschen, auch wenn es eigentlich das ...
Sind es arabische ... Nee, es sind nicht arabische, es sind arabische Zahlen.
Es sind arabische Zahlen. Es sind lateinische. Nee, auch nicht. Etruskisch. Ja, ist das ... Den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, tschüss, bis nächstes Jahr!
What?
Gab es eigentlich jemals eine Wette in der Folge, in der keine einzige Wette richtig gemacht wurde? Ja, manchmal gibt es gute Folgen, manchmal gibt es schlechte Tage, bis in ein paar Monaten, dann sind wir da. Wir schreiben im ... was? Stefan, dein Kopf glüht, dein Kopf raucht. Das ist tatsächlich das ... stefanteinische Alphabet. Du hast alles richtig gesagt. Du hast den Test bestanden. Wir hätten ohne weiteres auch einfach arabische Schriftzeichen und lateinische Zahlen haben können. Wir haben einfach alles genau andersrum gelegt. Ich glaube, Latein, die waren auch diese ganzen... War das nicht ein Kompromiss, dass man sagt, gut, ihr kriegt die Schriftzeichen und wir kriegen die Zahlen? Dafür kriegen wir diese Götter. Dafür nehmt ihr euren scheiß Elefantengott. Damit wollen wir gar nichts tun. Okay, dann nehmen wir unseren Elefantengott wieder mit. Was zählen Araber denn mit arabischen Ziffern? Ich glaube, die zählen mit so Stöcken im Sand. Also schreiben die Eins, also wie wir die Eins schreiben, oder? Ich habe keine Ahnung. Gibt es überhaupt noch andere? Also es gibt ja die römischen. Du, ein Arabisch-Kurs ist für 300 Dollar zu erwerben, das ist kein Problem. Die Inka greift zu. Maya oder Inka, die zählen ja nicht bei zehn, also wir haben ein zahlenbasiertes System, was auf zehn basiert, deren basiert auf zwölf, was auch oder sechs, aber auf jeden Fall halt einen Mehrwert von sechs, was ja auch interessant ist. Wir haben zehn, zwanzig, dreissig, das sind unsere runden Zahlen. Ach so, du meinst die Rundenzahlen? Deren sind zwölf. Ich lerne so viele gerade, ey. Es ist echt schwierig zu erklären. Die Zahlen zehn, zwanzig, dreissig nicht, aber das meinst du nicht. Nee, die haben die, weiß ich auch nicht. Aber das macht ja auch Sinn, weil, also Die fangen quasi an mit 12, also einundzwölfzig, dreihundzwölfzig, das ist quasi übertragen im Sinne der Zahlensystem. Ja, ich glaube nicht, dass du so ganz, dass das so wirklich stimmt. Ich glaube, es hat mehr was damit zu tun, dass du mit 12 besser zählen kannst. Also du kannst 12 wesentlich öfter teilen als 10. Also ich kann 10 durch zwei teilen und dann war's das. Aber ich kann 12 durch, und durch 5. Aber ich kann zwölf besser zählen kannst. Du kannst zwölf wesentlich öfter teilen als zehn. Ich kann zehn durch zwei teilen, und dann war's das. Und durch fünf. Und durch fünf. Aber ich kann zwölf durch zwei teilen, dann kann ich noch mal und ich kann zwölf durch drei teilen und vier teilen. Habt ihr Hemmungen, mit nassen Haaren rauszugehen? Oh. Oder habt ihr ... Ich wollte mir eigentlich noch die Haare waschen, bevor ich hierher komme. Ich auch. Ich dachte mir, ich will hier nicht mit nassen Haaren ankommen. Wir wollen nicht, dass du hier mit nassen Haaren ankommst. Ich weiß nicht genau, welches Bild man von jemandem hat, der mit nassen Haaren irgendwo auftaucht, aber ich dachte jetzt erst mal, ich bin nicht beliebt genug, um mein Aussehen so weit abzuhändern. Vor allem nicht in dieser Runde beliebt. Nicht in dieser Runde. Ich kann mal ohne Schuhe kommen, sowas, aber nicht mit nassen Haaren. Oder ohne Hose jetzt? Ja, aber nicht mit nassen Haaren. Nassen Haare ist so ein, weiß ich es tatsächlich bei anderen Leuten wesentlich, wie ja eigentlich alles in meinem ganzen Leben, wesentlich weniger schlimm als bei mir selbst. Also wenn jemand mit nassen Haaren hier aufkreuzen würde, einer von euch beiden zum Beispiel, dann würde ich eher denken, ja okay, der hat halt einfach wenig Zeit, wir haben ja auch geschrieben, und dann würde das ja Sinn machen, ah okay, die hatten wenig Zeit. Wenig Zeit, bei mir wäre seltsam. Ich habe eine Kurzehaarfrisur. Wenn ich mit nassen Haaren komme, müsste ich jetzt gerade die Haare gewaschen haben. Wenn ich hier die Haare gewaschen habe, wäre mega weird. Das ist wie so ein Tennisball. Hast du schon mal einen nassen Tennisball gesehen? Die sind instant trocken. Ja, voll trocken. Weil die ganz kurze Haare haben. Nein, nein, ein Tennisball. Ja, die haben ganz dünne Haare. Die haben doch total lange Haare. Ein Tennisball? Du hast dein Leben lang Falsch-Tennis gespielt. Nein, also das ist doch so, da wird so eine Hippie-Frisur. Mit so einem Ball, der die ganze Zeit so, nö, so Peace-Zeichen macht. Aber die haben doch so total quasi lange, aber wie so, wie halt Klettverschluss ist. Filz. Ich kann es nur wiederholen, das ist Filz. Ich glaube nicht, das ist Filz. Tennisfilz. Ist es Filz? Man nennt es Tennisfilz. Ja, aber Tennisbälle haben einfach nicht lange Haare, da können wir uns auch nicht lange drüber reden. Okay, Entschuldigung. Die sind einfach wohl gekämmt. Nee, die sind ja gar nicht gekämmt. Die sind eben das genaue Gegenteil von gekämmt. Gibt es, ist jede Sportart optimiert? Nein, auf gar keinen Fall. Nämlich, warum spielt man Tennis nicht mit einem Flummi? Ist der nicht viel krasser als ein Tennisball? Zu krass. Also ich würde sagen, man müsste Tennis mit einem Flummi, aber dann auf einem, ich sag mal, 16 Mal so grossen Spielfeld spielen. Das wäre interessant. Du kannst dann halt nicht, das kann keine Schlägerbewegungen mehr. Und das, was den Tennis so attraktiv macht, stöhnende Frauen. Du hast einfach nur Leute, die den Schläger hinhalten und du kannst da nicht so durchschlagen. Du kannst da trotzdem noch draufschlagen. Du kannst nicht durchballern. Klar, Flumi, dann ist der ganz schnell. Flumi doch weg. Du musst erzielen. Eben, und der andere muss so gut sein. Da kannst du nicht draufballern. Flumi spielt doch viel zu schnell von irgendwelchen weg. Ja, genau. Aber du willst doch, dass er schnell ist. Du willst ja gewinnen. Das ist ja so, als wir sagen, beim Tennis darfst du aber nicht hartschlagen. Ich spreche mit jemandem, der Leistungsklasse 14 war, der sieben Jahre lebenslang Profitennis gespielt hat. Nein. Aber ich war zumindest in so einer Rangliste, aber da war ich nicht besonders gut. Also im Internet hast du dich einfach in irgendeine Liste eingetragen. Ja, ich war einfach alphabetisch sortiert. Naja, ich habe lange Tennis gespielt. Und wenn du beim Flummi durchschwingst, hast du keine Chance, dass er jemals woanders hinkommt. Wie woanders benutzt die deutsche Sprache, Stefan! Auf den anderen Platz, auf das Feld, was du anvisierst. Warum, du kannst das doch zielen! Aber dann kann der nicht zurückschlagen. Ja, aber das ist nicht dein Problem! Aber der Sport ist doch dann langweilig! Du willst doch, das ist ja so, als würde ich sagen, du verbietest beim Tennis einen harten Schlag, weil das ja, dann kann der andere Linie gar nicht erreichen. Nein, nein, nein, das ist nicht mein Argument. Mein Argument ist, wenn ich draufschlage, gut, dann habe ich vielleicht den Punkt, der Gegner kriegt den Ball aber nie in seinem Leben und das Spiel ist boring. Sobald der Ball hat die perfekte Stärke, damit ein cooles Match entstehen kann, was spannend ist, wo es um Technik geht und nicht wer den ersten Schlag hat. Also der Sport ist nicht optimiert, er ist nicht so krass wie sein können. Aber das ist die Frage, was optimiert will ich heißen, das ist natürlich die Frage. Ja, so schnell wie es geht,haltsam. Ja, aber möglich unterhaltsam wäre auch, dann könntest du ja auch, der Boden ist Lava, also tatsächlich Lava. Also nicht unterhaltsam. Das wäre unterhaltsam. Für jemanden, der es guckt, fände ich es unterhaltsam. Ja, aber wer bestimmt das? Klavier Torbekämpfe sind bis heute Hands Down beste Sportart. Ja, aber wenn ich jetzt sag, hey, mir würde Fussball mehr Spaß machen, wenn die Tore grösser werden, dann sagt der Unterhaltsamsschieds, sagt, nein, das wäre nicht unterhaltsamer. Wer legt das denn fest, was unterhaltsam ist und was nicht? Das ist der Unterhaltsams-Schiedsrichter. Ich kriege ab und zu ein paar Formulare. Neulich kam die Idee, den Schiedsrichter beim Tennis noch ein bisschen höher zu setzen. Das fand ich gut, das ist lustig. Zehnmal so! Das fand ich hilarious, habe ich gesagt, ja, klar, easy, kein Problem. Ich frage mich ja wirklich, wie das passiert. das das passiert ist. Hat da irgendwie mal jemand, der eigentlich in seinem Nebenbein auch Jäger ist, irgendwie das machen müssen und dann hat er seinen Jägerhochsitz mit da hingenommen. Kein Becker, Optimacus. Zwei Klappen mit einer Fiege. Nee, eigentlich da hinten ist dieses Rehe, was ich unbedingt schießen will, und ich muss ja auf dieses Spiel aufpassen, ich nehme jetzt einfach meinen Hochsitz mit und dadurch ist es passiert und dann irgendwann ist es zu Plastik geworden. Oder hat das mal ein Baby gemacht und das war so so ein ganz hoher, kenn diese Plastik, diese Plastikhochstuhlen im Restaurant zum Beispiel. Warum sitzen Babys höher, also warum sitzen Babys nicht genauso am Tisch, dass quasi die Ellenbogen mit dem Tisch abschliessen, wie normale Menschen? Das wäre eigentlich perfekt. Babys sitzen noch höher. Das stimmt. Und haben ihren eigenen kleinen Tisch. Wahrscheinlich damit die Eltern sehen können, was die Babys machen. Unterm Tisch. Ich habe auch mal den Satz gehört, ich weiß nicht wo, aber dass ein Schlag mit einem Boxhandschuh mehr Schaden anrichtet als ein Schlag mit der Faust. Okay, das glaube ich nicht. Und das stimmt nicht, da sind wir uns einig. Er ist ja weich, der Handschuh, da sind wir uns auch einig. Gut, das ist natürlich die Frage, was jetzt mehr Schaden heißt. Vielleicht kann ich ja dadurch, dass meine Hand, also ich habe schon einmal in meinem ganzen Leben einem anderen Menschen ins Gesicht gehauen, mit der Faust, es tat so weh, wie ich es mir nicht vorgestellt habe. Aber so richtig volle Lotte oder was? Nein, ich habe, also ich kann, mit so ungefähr 21 kmh vielleicht. Aber jetzt gemessen an deiner Fähigkeit, wie viel Prozent deiner Kraft hast du reingelegt? Die Hälfte, also ich hätte noch mehr drauf. Aber warum bist du sauer, also du bist so sauer, dass du ihn schlägst, aber so sauer, dass du nur mit 50 Prozent schlägst. Weil ich mich nicht getraut habe. Wie sauer warst du, was ist passiert? Die haben meine damalige Freundin geärgert. Was war das jetzt für ein Geräusch? Nee, ich muss sagen, geärgert, ich fand die Wortwahl lustig.
Es klang so, als ob die im Kindergarten war und die haben die ganze Lebersteine hergenommen.
Ich war in der siebten Klasse, glaube ich, siebte, achte Klasse, irgendwie sowas.
Also ich war wirklich nicht alt.
Und dann habe ich den halt, und der war auch einfach ein Arsch.
Also es war halt auch einfach so ein klassischer Bulli.
Und ich dachte mir, ich war immer sehr klein, jetzt bin ich nicht mehr klein, und ich war immer sehr klein, also einer der kleinsten, da war ich gerade so in der Pubertät und war groß und dachte mir, ja, ich bin jetzt halt grösser als du. Und dann habe ich ihn gehauen. Und es tat wirklich richtig weh, weil ich habe genau auf den Wangenknochen getroffen. Und es tat mir wirklich an meinen Knöcheln, also an meinen, sind das hier die Knöchel oder das hier? Nee, durchaus. Sind das alles die, und was sind das hier? Finger, Fingerballen. Neinen. Nein, Ballen. Das hier meine ich. Ja. Das hier sind doch die Knöchel. Wenn ich jetzt das hier mache. Ich glaube, technisch gesehen hat jeder Finger drei Knöchel dann eigentlich, oder? Ja, wahrscheinlich. Nee, Gelenk, Fingergelenk. Ja, aber wo ist der? Warte, heisst es Fußgelenk oder Fußknöchel? Ich bin immer noch. Stefan, das ist bei der Matratze immer noch. Ja, ich bin immer noch faszinierend. Okay, und hat's funktioniert, hast du ihn in die Flucht geschlagen, den Rüpel? Ja, schon. Also ich hab kurzfristig schon, aber danach hat er ... Von der Angst, dass er zurückschlägt, ne? Ja, ich hab ihn auch gehauen, bin auch einfach, also ich hab quasi gehauen und in der Bewegung hab ich mich umgedreht und bin gegangen. Sehr gut. Aber ich weiß, dass sie dann auch sich zusammen gerottet haben und es hat auch, glaube ich, geklingelt und die Pause war irgendwie zu Ende. Ja, aber es war auch mein ... Storyende, Endcredits kamen. Ja, es war leider nicht Storyende, denn dann am Ende kam ein noch bulligerer Bulli. Ah, Next Level. Genau, Next Level quasi. Und der war auch einen Kopf grösser als ich und kam nach der Schule auf mich zu in einem sehr schnellen Schritte, quasi gerade als die Stunde, also als ich aus der Tür rauskam. Hoppserlauf oder also wie war es schon Sprint oder? Weil diese Fussballläufe, die immer so seitlich gehen, aber sehr schnell seitlich gehen. Dieser Krabbengang, ja. Krabbengang. Oder so zwei Schritte vor, eine zurück, aber richtig schnell. Eyichtig schnell. Auf jeden Fall einfach schnell, wie diese Schnellläufer, die aber nicht laufen, sondern gehen. Ja, ah, Walken. Genau, Walken. Ich würde so gerne das Ende der Story erfahren. Bei Walken sind nie beide Füsse in der Luft. Ja, auf jeden Fall so. Wie viele Füsse waren in der Luft? Entweder war das die Regel bei Walken, oder lauft maximal bescheuert. Also ich glaube, das Ergebnis ist das gleiche. Vielleicht haben auch zwei so debattiert, und das war am Ende der Nächste auch egal. Also er kam auf dich zu. Genau, schnell und ich war sehr verängstigt. Ich bin rückwärts dann quasi vor ihm weggegangen. Das sah noch lächerlicher aus, weil ich hatte halt einfach Riesenschiss, weil er sah auch sehr böse, also mit böses Gesicht aus. Ja. Ja, es war kurz nach Sport, soweit ich weiß, weil ich hatte nämlich noch meinen Badminton-Schläger in der Hand. Ja, hallo! Perfekte Situation, ich hau ihn um! Da dachte ich die ganze Zeit auch. Ich spiele Badminton mit ihm da jetzt. Forder ihn heraus, er muss annehmen. Er muss die Herausforderung annehmen. In einem spannenden Duell der Badminton heraus. Pardon, Federball. Und er hat halt gesagt, ja, leg dich doch das nächste Mal mit deiner Grösse an, obwohl er auch einen Kopf grösser war als ich, wie ich schon einen Kopf grösser als der davor war. Schwierig, jemanden seiner Größe zu finden. Und der hat jetzt, weil du gegen den Bulli-Code verstoßen hast, kam er auf den Platz der Freundchen. Nein, das war auch ein Freund von dem Bulli, glaube ich.. Und da hat er mir ziemlich deftig eine gescheuert, aber nicht mit der Faust, sondern mit der flachen Hand. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich darüber wirklich glücklich bin, dann nochmal. Und die ganze Zeit dachte ich mir, warum haue ich ihn nicht und dann bin ich abgehauen. Also rechts, rechts, zwei Ohrfeigen. Ich weiß es wirklich nicht mehr. Oder rechts, links. Wie beim Verhör oder was? Ich glaube rechts, rechts. Was willst du da aus? Das ist eine ganz, ich finde das nicht, das ist eine ult ultra merkwürdige Situation, jemanden zweimal eine zu scheuern mit der gleichen Hand. Nein, er hat mir eine gescheuert und dann geredet, so auf mich eingeredet, so dummer, hier Beleidigungen einfügen und dann hat er mir noch eine gescheuert. Ich glaube, ich fände es unglaublich schwer, die Distanz richtig einzuschätzen, weil du willst nicht zu kurz für so ein, du willst aber auch nicht so einen richtigen, weil irgendwann wird es ja dann, also dann kommt der Handballen ins Spiel und dann schlägst du den ja richtig. Ich glaube, instinktiv willst du aber auch. Oder irgendwann kommt man so mit dem Ellbogen gegen den Kopf. Irgendwann mit so einer Umarmung, dann geht's wieder. Aber dazwischen ist so eine, so eine, ja die Todessage. Boxen, ich habe selten Boxen, bin immer fasziniert, wenn ich das sehe, wie abends, aber es ist sehr viel, es ist 50% Kampf, 50% umarmen. Weil ihr dann immer, immer zwischen... Immer Aussöhnung wieder. Und dann der Richter... Ich meine das nicht so. Ich dachte immer, der Richter will die auseinander treiben, aber der will dann wieder, dass die sich wieder schlagen. Das ist ja lustig, wenn die es dann umarmen und dann so angeklammert haben, dann zieht der sich wieder auseinander, damit sie sich wieder schlagen können. Aber ich bin mir tatsächlich immer unsicher, ob dieses Umarmen ist quasi, ist das was Taktisches? Ja, Taktisches. Ich dachte ganz oft, also ich gucke jetzt nicht so oft wie Stefan, der jetzt schon zum zweiten Mal das Boxthema angefangen hat. Oh, neuer Stefan, neue Phase. Neue Boxphase, ich gucke jetzt nicht so oft Boxen, aber immer wenn ich so irgendwelche Ausschnitte sehe, dann und dieses Umarmen, bin ich mir nicht sicher, okay, ist das jetzt irgendwie was Taktisches, damit der andere nicht mehr zuhören kann, oder ist es so, ja okay, tut mir leid für den letzten Schlag, weil das könnte beides sein, weil die auch immer so, die haben auch immer so einen exakt gleichen Gesichtsausdruck, weil ich glaube, das müssen sie sich auch antrainieren, dass sie nicht mehr böse gucken, wenn die einen schlagen wollen. Das ist Pokerface, das dürfen Sie sich anmerken lassen, was Ihnen geht. Boxingface. Das stimmt. Ich glaube, das ist so ein PR-Ding, dass der Marketing sagt, wir wollen, dass du noch
Orangensaft verkaufen kannst nach dem Match.
Also schlag den jetzt nicht zu blutig Brei, sondern lass auch mal irgendwie so eine zärtliche Geste mit einfließen, irgendwie so ein High Five oder sowas. Einfach damit sowas zwischendrin erfolgt. Gibt es eigentlich Boxen für Kinder? Gibt es also direkt nächste Idee, gibt es Boxen mit Kindern, also sprich, ich kämpfe gegen Kinder. So ein Mixed Group. Boxen auch gegen Frauen, weißt du? Ja, auch gegen Frauen, aber gegen Kinder fand ich jetzt eher interessant. Dann reden wir darüber, wie du willst. Also einfach gegen mehrere Kinder quasi, das ist so ausgeglichen, dass man so sagt, okay, Florentin hat eine Stärke von einem Einem Kind, exakt, einem anderen Kind. Einem dicken Kind. Nein, nein, nein, die Dicke, von einer Dicken. Und zwar, das ist mal quasi so eine Skala von eins bis tausend, hundert. Und Florentin hat eine Stärke von acht, Stefan von zwölf und ein Kind von drei.
Und dann kriege ich noch vier Kinder, dann das fair ist.
Genau, dann kriegst du vier Kinder und so weiter, dass es so aufgewogen wird.
Und dann andere kriegen dann halt, wo die eine ungerade Zahl haben,
kriegen dann halt drei Kinder und ein Säugling oder ähnliches.
Ganz kurz Breaking News, Leute.
Mach die Breaking News-Musik.
Dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann. Ich habe gerade Alphabet gegoogelt, weil ich immer noch, also das war schon länger her, eben bei der Story, da wir gerade darüber gesprochen haben, und eben geht mein Auge so rüber, um nochmal auf mein Bildschirm zu gucken, wo ich immer noch von damals Alphabet gegoogelt habe, und tatsächlich ist etwas passiert, also Alphabet wurde zu Alphabet, der Mutterkonzern von Google, und es ist Folgendes passiert, gerade in der Welt, Kenia. Googles Internetballon sorgt für Massenauflauf und zerstörte Felder. Bauer will Alphabet verklagen. In Kenia ist dieser Google-Ballon abgestürzt. Warte, sind wir jetzt gerade im Das Podcast-Ufo-Podcast oder im Gute-Arbeit-Impro-Podcast? Womit sind wir im Das Podcast-Ufo-Podcast-Podcast? Meinst du mit Ballon jetzt sowas wie eine Finanzblase oder einen echten physischen Ballon? Warum schwebt über Kenia ein Google-Ballon und was macht er da? Also was ist ein Google-Ballon? Die wollen Internetzugänge in fremde Gebiete bringen. Mit einem Ballon. Aber der Internet-Ballon ist abgestürzt. Ja, und kanny nicht einfach abschießen? Da ist unten so ein Router dran.
Unten haben sie so einen Router und dann ist er jetzt abgestürzt und hat für ein Zerstattesfeld gesorgt.
Lest euch da mal rein. Das ist keine gute Nachrichtensendung, aber ich bin dafür, dass wir zumindest manchmal so ein bisschen Breaking News reinbringen.
Aber zum Thema umarmen, ich weiß nicht. Für 2018 auf jeden Fall ein guter Vorsitz.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es mitbekommen habe, aber der Weltrekord in den meisten Umarmungen wurde ja gebrochen letztes Jahr. Von deiner Mutter. Oh, an Weihnachten! Ne, schaut euch auf YouTube mal ein Video an. World Record Most Hugs. Es ist ein absolut interessantes Video, absoluter Hochleistungssport, athletische Maximalleistung, die da begann wird. Aber in einer bestimmten Zeit. Richtig, in einer gewissen Zeit. Das hast du jetzt nicht gesagt, ich dachte jetzt einfach nur um, also generell. Ne, nee, die schnellsten, ich glaube es ist in einer Minute, die meisten Umarmungen in einer Minute, schaut es euch an, da ist auf jeden Fall ein Visionär. Es verliert seinen emotionalen Reiz auch, die Umarmung, oder? Ich sage mal, die letzten 20 kommen nicht mehr so gut weg emotional. Ist es noch weit weg von sich schlagen dann auch? Schaut es euch an, also ich sage nur, es ist ein Mann, eine Vision, die er durchgezogen hat und er hat seinen Lebensziel erreicht, er hat diesen Weltrekord gebrochen mit den meisten Umarmungen. Das war mein Video der Woche, cool. Apropos, ich kann jetzt mal aufklären, was es hiermit auf sich hat. Du schreibst Whatsapps an dich selber als Notizfunktion. Frage, warum nimmst du nicht die Notiz-App, die dafür vorgesehen ... Wenn du sie darauf findest? Oh, tschau, oh, kann Stefan aus Osterode in 20 Minuten die Notiz-App auf dem Handy des 300-Dollar-ärmeren Mannes finden? Top-Dierte-Geld. 20 Minuten ab jetzt. Stefan hat noch nichts gefunden.
Abbruch. Abbruch, okay, Stefan liegt mit rotem Kopf auf dem Boden, er bewegt sich nicht mehr. Wir müssen abbrechen. Seine Hand zittert noch. Ja, habe ich nicht gefunden. Mein Handy hat einfach keine Notizfunktion. Das ist leider der sehr, ja, also das ist einfach der Klimax der Story. Gut, cool. Und genau diese Notizsache hat mich daran erinnert, also hat mich nicht daran erinnert, sondern habe ich nach dem benannt, was ihr beide mich gelehrt habt. Also Florian und Steffen. Was ihr beide mich gelehrt habt, nämlich das Leben ist kein Podcast kein Podcast. Ja, das stimmt. Das stimmt, und zwar bin ich darauf gekommen, es ist jetzt nicht so lustig, was ich jetzt erzähle. Du, ey, wir können gerne auch mal tiefer in deine Geschichte hineingehen. Und zwar, es ist jetzt auch nicht, es ist eigentlich nichts so, es ist auch nicht wirklich tiefsinnig oder philosophisch oder interessant. Wollen wir einfach eine andere Geschichte erzählen? Ich bin mir nicht er erzählen? Nee, also und zwar, ihr greift ja oft Themen auf, oder also ihr redet ja über Sachen und also ich weiß nicht. Nee, wir greifen Themen auf. Ich lasse ihn schon beim Namen nennen. Dankeschön, ist das Lob? Ihr redet ja über Sachen. Also ihr redet in Mikrofone, das stimmt schon mal auf jeden Fall, das sehe ich nämlich gerade, eigentlich bin ich auch nur deswegen gekommen, um das zu überprüfen, nein und zwar, oft kommt ein Thema dadurch, dass einer von euch irgendwas erzählt, zum Beispiel, mir ist aufgefallen das, oder ist es nicht so das, oder mit einer Anekdote oder einem Gag oder was auch immer, dann greift der andere das auf und ihr redet darüber und es entsteht ein fulminanter, also ein mittelmässig bis fulminanter Podcast daraus.
Wow, danke. Dann lernt unser Geheimnis. Im Leben funktioniert das leider nicht so ganz, denn ich habe, das muss ich zu meiner Schande gestehen, oft schon Geschichten, die ihr hier erzählt habt, als meine eigenen ausgegeben. Sehr gut. Bei Freunden, weil ich einfach, weil mir, also ihr sagt ja immer, ach, uns passiert ja gar nichts und unser Leben ist langweilig. Mein Leben ist tatsächlich langweilig, mir passiert wirklich nichts, so wenn es nichts, was interessant genug wäre, um es meinen Leuten zu erzählen, die ich neu kennenlerne. Und dann erzähle ich immer, dass mir irgendwas passiert ist. Und oft erzähle ich nicht nur Geschichten, also das ist eigentlich das meiste, dass ich irgendwas kriege, ach, das ist letztens meistens, sage ich, einem Freund von mir passiert oder auch mir, sondern oft irgendwelche Gags, die zu lustigen Themen oder interessanten Unterhaltungen zwischen euch geführt sind, greife ich auf, bring die eine Runde und dann irgendjemand, hä, stimmt doch gar nicht, und dann ist das so ein Tisch. Tatsächlich, das fällt auf, rede niemals mit Leuten, die mehr Ahnung haben, das ist gut, weil wir beide haben ein gefährliches Halbwissen von Dingen. Ja, natürlich. Ich habe auch Halbwissen von ungefähr all, also ja, aber das ist nicht mal unbedingt das Wissen, sondern auch so diese Haltung. Und das fand ich sehr interessant. Das ist mir irgendwann so nach sechs Jahren, nachdem ich seit ich einen Podcast höre, aufgefallen, dass ich das einfach nicht mehr machen kann. Dass Leute nicht so auf Dinge reagieren, wie es in einem Podcast passiert. Und das ist, ihr seid ja da nicht die Ausnahme. Es ist ja eigentlich oft in einem Podcast, dass ein Thema von einem der Gesprächspartner angesprochen wird und der andere greift es dann auf und daraus entsteht dann ein Gespräch. Ja, und dahingehend habe ich diese Notizgruppe was oder geöffnet. Ich finde vor allem das gerade gut, dass man dann bei WhatsApp sich selber schreiben kann, weil jeder kennt das aber mit auf Partys zu sein. Und dann ist man alleine in der Ecke und hat sein Getränk in der Hand und man grüßt kurz den Gastgeber, und dann kennt man halt niemanden mehr. Und man guckt sich in der Ecke um und klopft sich auf die Oberschenkel. Und dann das Handy rausnehmen und mit sich selber zu schreiben, ist schon ganz schön gut. Ich mach das auch sehr häufig, weil ich da halt ... Ich hab bestimmt, ich glaub, sechs Notiz Notizgruppen. Sechs Konversen mit dir selber. Ja, also ja, weil du kannst dich nicht selbst anschreiben, sondern nur eine Gruppe eröffnen mit jemand anderem, den dann rausschmeissen und dann noch mit dir selber schreiben. Sehr gut. Und das hab ich jetzt schon sechs Mal gemacht. Mit dem gleichen Freund, der immer sauer wird. Aber ich hab sie dann, ich hab sie nach dem dritten Mal dann erklärt, warum ich das gemacht habe. Weil sie hat mich die ersten zwei Male noch gefragt und dann hat sie gesagt, ach so, ja, ich mache das übrigens, weil ich mir selbst schreiben kann. Aber man kann eine Gruppe aufmachen mit einer anderen Person? Ja, natürlich. Nee, nicht natürlich, weil das ist ja eine Konversation mit der Person. Aber du kannst ja auch eine Gruppe mit zwei anderen Leuten aufmachen. Ja, genau. Ja, und dann eine rausschmeissen oder nicht. Das wäre ja total dumm, wenn dann auf einmal die ganze Gruppe ist. Natürlich macht das Sinn, aber direkt mit einer Person ein anderes Gespräch aufzumachen, macht ja keinen Sinn.
Naja, das habe ich aber auch schon mit Leuten gemacht,
wo ich dann mit einer Freundin hatte ich, glaube ich, sechs Gruppen.
Und die waren alle unterteilt in dringend,
in eins war die normale Gruppe, Normalsprache.
Flirt.
Genau, Flirt hatten wir auch eine.
Das muss schon alles erinnern.
Genau, das hatten wir dann alles so.
Und so konnten wir auch, das war irgendwann so genial, wir konnten irgendwann mehrere Unterhaltungen gleichzeitig führen. Weil jetzt seit, ich weiß nicht, einem halben Jahr oder einem Jahr kann man ja auf bestimmte Nachrichten antworten. Ja, ja. Aber das ging ja nicht schon immer. Nee. Und deswegen wusste man nie, so wenn man jetzt sechs Nachrichten, so zum Beispiel, okay, was essen wir heute, wann treffen wir uns und wer kommt noch alles? Okay, das sind jetzt Antworten, worauf offensichtlich Antworten Sinn machen, aber zum Beispiel sowas wie
hast du schon das Bad geputzt,
bist du noch zu Hause
oder hast du schon was zu essen
gekocht? So, und dann, ja, nein, ja,
also das erste Jahr, also, ne, und dann
du weißt ja auch nie, wie die Nachrichten angekommen sind,
ob vielleicht bei der einen Nachricht Funkloch war
und bei der anderen ist auch schon angekommen oder ähnliches.
Und dann haben wir so halt
mehrere Konversationen gleichzeitig geführt und ich fand mich damals schon sehr visionär, revolutionär, bis dann halt diese Antwortfunktion von WhatsApp kam, aber das fand ich schon sehr geil. Wir haben dann tatsächlich manchmal drei bis vier Chats gleichzeitig geschrieben und haben immer über andere Sachen geschrieben, je nachdem es um ein anderes Thema ging. Cool. Kennt ihr das so, weil du gerade gesagt hast, auf Partys man ist verloren so ein bisschen und also zum Beispiel sowas irgendwie Taufe oder Hochzeit oder sowas und man ist in einer ganz grossen Gruppe, man muss da sein und dann geht man auf die Toilette und betritt diesen Raum und denkt sich so ha, ja, hier das ist mein Reich. Hier geht's mir gut. Hier bin ich zu Hause. Und bleibt ihr dann auch manchmal länger auf der Ja, natürlich. Und ich gehe alle zehn Minuten. Und ich denke mir so, das erste Mal auf einer neuen Location, Taufe oder so, danach wird noch gegessen. Und das erste Mal in der Stadt ist, ist so ein bisschen wie eine neue Wohnung. Guckt sich oben so, ah, so eine Art. So eine Wohnung für die nächsten paar Stunden. Genau, es ist so ein bisschen so, hier bin ich Mensch, hier darf ich sein, das ist mein Raum. Hier gucke ich mir auch mal einen Porno auf dem Handy an, ohne dazu zu masturbieren. Hier mache ich innerlich den Hosenknopf auf. Hier lasse ich ein bisschen meinen sozialen Schild fallen. Und hier bin ich selbst ein bisschen. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Man guckt sich auch ein bisschen um, wie ist diese Schlette aufgebaut. Kabinen sind eben unterschiedlich aufgebaut. Ja, wie viel Platz hat man? Kabinen sind natürlich auch was ganz anderes. Aber wie nicht? Ich bin hier von privaten, von privaten. Nee, nee, irgendwie auch so, keine Ahnung, Restaurant.
Taufe, ich habe ja gesagt, du machst einfach nur zuhören.
Ich habe ja gesagt, Taufe oder Hochzeit, und danach geht man noch schön Schmauz.
Sehr konkret auch.
Also zum Beispiel, je nachdem, kann jetzt auch eine, ich weiß nicht, ist es eine katholische Taufe oder eine evangelische Taufe, je nachdem.
Wird man eigentlich nur bei den Christen getauft?
Wird eigentlich irgendwas mit dem Kind bei den ... Ich darf es nicht weiter sagen. Moslemann. Nee, weiß ich nicht. Ich hab nämlich in der Schule mehrfach, ich glaub zwei oder drei Mal, auch so sehen Islamisten gesagt, weil mir das Wort für Moslem nicht eingefallen ist. Nee, weil das Wort auch geläufiger ist, ganz im Ernst. Nein, nicht nur das, sondern es macht ja auch viel mehr, also klar, also hat er das gesagt?
Also es stimmt, weil es ja mehr in den Medien ist.
2018 wird hot, hot, hot, hot, hot, hot, hot, hot.
Aber es kommt ja auch von dem Wort Islam.
Also die Religion heisst ja Islam. Wir verstehen alle das Problem.
Wir alle hatten das Problem schon mal.
Es ist doch ein geschissener Kacker.
Ja, ja.
Ne, wo war ich? Ach ja, genau.
Taufe. Es gibt Bar Mitzwa im Judentum.
Es gibt die Beschneidung bei Moslems.
Du verwechselst da gerade was.
Und außerdem ist die Bar Mitzwa im Judentum. Es gibt die Beschneidung bei Moslems.
Und außerdem ist die Bar Mitzwa ja auch erst, wenn du zwölf oder dreizehn bist oder vierzehn.
Ja, ich beform die nicht.
Ja, aber das meine ich ja, weil die Taufe ist ja beim Christentum dafür da, um dich in die Religion ein.
Also sozusagen hier das heilige Wasser und deswegen bist du jetzt zum Christentum.
Unabhängig davon check ich schon mal nicht, dass Jesus ein Jude war, aber er ist Christus. Und dann gibt es noch die, die sagen, die sind Juden und sagen, ja, wir sind aber trotzdem Juden geblieben. Wir bleiben bei den Prequels. Wir sind die Prequel-Religionen. Klar, es gibt noch irgendwie sieben, acht, neun Episode, aber wir sind die Alten. Und die Christen sagen so, ey, wir finden es alles mega geil, was damals passiert ist, und Jesus war Jude. Und die Moslems sagen, die Bibel ist zu lustig. Ja, aber einfach, dass es auch so die Prequel-Religionen gibt, die einfach sagt, wir bleiben dran. Das ist genau wie man heute noch jemand an Zeus gehört, die einfach sagen so, nee, die hatten es damals schon recht. Das habe ich mir auch letztens überlegt, wir hatten nämlich in der, ich mache gerade eine Ausbildung, hatten wir in der Schule. Worin? Mediengestalter, Bild und Turum. Mhm, cool. Ja, danke. Und da hatten wir in der Schule das Fach, es heißt zwar Politik, aber es ist mehr so Gesellschaft, Philosophie, alles, alles zusammen, wir diskutieren halt über alles Mögliche. Und da haben wir irgendwann über Entstehung geredet, über Entstehungsgeschichte. Und der Lehrer hat halt nur gefragt, er wollte halt darauf auf den Urknall hinaus, er hat gefragt, was ist so die most common Schöpfungsgeschichte. Und da haben halt viele gesagt, ja, hier irgendwie, also er hat erst nur gefragt, glaube ich, was ist die Schöpfungsgeschichte und dann hat halt eine Schülerin, die total der Freak, also nicht Freak, total der Nerd, also so sehr, die ist halt sehr in der, ich glaube es war griechische Mythologie oder die römische, es ist das gleiche, nur mit anderen Worten, die ist sehr gleich, ja, und hat auf jeden Fall davon die Schöpfungsgeschichte mit hier Krautus oder so, Kronos, der irgendwie was gemacht hat, erzählt und so total detailliert und ich dachte mir so, das ist ja so interessant, wenn ich jetzt zu einem gläubigen, also zu einem wirklich gläubigen Menschen, zu einem gläubigen Christen, Juden oder Moslem oder was auch immer gehen würde und sagen würde, ja, hey, was hältst du denn von Christen, Juden, dann würden die sagen, ja, ist nicht meine Religion, aber die sind ja gläubig, aber wenn ich sagen würde, was hältst du denn von jemandem, der an die griechische Mythologie glaubt, dann würden doch voll viele sagen, ja, das ist doch total bescheuert.
Ich würde sagen, es ist mega cool.
Ich finde es auch irgendwie cool, weil so ein gläubiger Christ sagt,
das ist doch komisch.
Ey, wie glaubt man einen Typen, der in Sandalen durch die Wüste gelaufen ist und man weiß nicht genau, er hat diesen Blinden geheilt
oder war es doch ein Assistent von ihm oder so, man weiß es nicht.
Aber das ist halt alles so strange.
Und dann gab es halt diese eine Religion, wo es den Gott des Krieges gibt. Ja, Mars, den kann man so angucken im Himmel, den sehe ich da, Gott sehe ich nicht. Hast du das Röschel im Mars gesehen? Klar. Ich glaube sogar, dass technisch gesehen Jesus nicht mal auf dem Wasser gelaufen ist, sondern irgendjemand wurde von einem Boot geschobst und dann konnte der über Wasser laufen und Jesus hat so gesagt, ja, das war übrigens ich. Jesus hat ein Foto gemacht. Ich glaube wirklich, dass es nicht so... Jesus hat sich reingeschoppt in das Foto. Der hat später behauptet so, by the way, falls ihr euch fragt, wie das sein konnte, das war ich. Ich glaube, es war ein Vater Morgana, wo so ein Fluss in der Wüste zu sehen ist und er stellt sich so drauf und sagt so, wow, wow, seht ihr das, seht ihr das? Lauf mal hin, lauf mal hin, lauf mal hin, nicht da, das war eine geile Zeit, wie geil die Zeit gewesen sein muss, als man keinen Plan von gar nichts hatte und man dachte sich so, Blitz, what the fuck, alter Blitz und heute so, interessiert mich nicht, kann ich auf Wikipedia nachgucken, aber damals, Blitz, hallo, Blitz? Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ja, ist einfach, genau, Zeus, auch cooler Charakter.
Vor allem ist es die griechische und römische, ich weiß auch nicht genau, wo das ist, aber die Mythologie ist einfach wie so eine grosse Soap, weil erstmal haben ja alle haben mit allen was und dann diese ganzen, das geht ja dann auch so Forrest Gump-mäßig in die richtige Realität rein mit Troja und so ein krassem Kram. Stimmt, ja, ja. Das spielt ja so rein, man weiss nicht, was Realität ist,
das finde ich der Forrest Gumpel-Fake so.
Und dann gibt's dann die Andromeda und Agamemnon und die Helena und diesen Halbgott und der Achilles ist der, der in der Ferse sterben kann. Keine Ahnung, wie das möglich ist. Doch nicht so ein Supergott, aber dann geht es halt so da rein. Aber das ist so in der Bibel auch so, da gibt es ja auch dann hier Jesus, ist ja auch als historische Figur und so diese ganzen Völkerwanderungen und mehr. In der Bibel spielt ja alles auf der Erde, prinzipiell erstmal. Es spielt ja alles auf der Erde, also es gibt ja nicht das Kapitel Himmel. Es gibt ja auch so bei Himmelsszenen, wo, klar, Interior Himmel und dann halt so Gott und Ezekiel oder so. Interior Himmel, so Light Jazz läuft im Hintergrund. Welche Musik läuft in der Hölle? Ich würde jetzt... Death Metal ist wahrscheinlich nicht das naheliegendste. Sorry, ich weiß, ich bin noch nicht drin. Ich wollte auch gerade sagen, ich dachte du, ach, deswegen wurde... Ich will es nicht ansprechen. Deswegen wurde gute Arbeit gekriegt. Danke, Stefan. Ja, sorry, ich hätte halt nicht so gute Ideen mehr. Irgendwann war ich erschöpft. Ich finde Alexa so lustig. Jetzt Lord and Mansion, die Alexa heißen? Nein, diese Geräte, die Amazon Echoes. Tatsächlich kann man, das ist das Lustigste, ich kann darüber herzhaft lachen. Hast du so eins jetzt? Nein, aber eine Freundin hat das und wir haben abends einen Abend bei der verbracht und der Kommando Alexa spiele Death Metal auf Lautstärke 10 ist der beste Gag aller Zeiten. Es ist immer lustig, weil tatsächlich, wenn es mit Spotify verbunden ist, spielt immer das gleiche Death Metal Lied. Und dann hat man ja manchmal Pech, wenn du so eine Death Metal Liste anmachst, dass dann nicht sofort das Death Metal Lied rauskommt. Alexa hat da ein Händchen für. Es wird das, was sofort in Takt 1 macht. Aber in Lautstärkeärke zehn ist die lautes Lautstärke, was ich auch nicht dachte. Wir haben erst hundert gesagt. Zehn? Ja, zehn gibt es nur eins bis zehn. Also kann man denn wenigstens noch stufen, also sowas wie eins Komma fünf oder eins Komma eins? Nee, nee, eins bis zehn. Das ist scheiße. Nee, es reicht. Erstaunlicherweise reicht. Ich dachte auch erst nicht detailliert genug, aber... Nee, also das Problem, ich habe das so Problem so, dass in den unteren Bereichen, wenn ein Audiosystem, ob es jetzt Kopfhörer oder Lautsprecher sind, im unteren, oder ist ja egal, woher diese Regelung kommt, im unteren Bereich nicht detailliert genug ist, dann finde ich das schwach, weil... Hier kommt der Bild- und Tonmeister. Ich hätte es nicht sagen sollen. Ihr seid doch hier in der Bild- und Tonmeisterhaftigkeit. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie der Laden hier ist. Nee, also ich finde es nicht schwach von dem technischen, sondern von dem persönlichen Sinn her, weil ich gerne ab und zu mal auch leise Musik im Hintergrund laufen lasse. Zumindest keine gute Qualität auch. Nee, nicht Qualität, sondern dass du zwischen... Ich bin bereit für alle Wege, alle Wege stehen dir offen. Ich habe auf jeden Fall immer recht. recht. Ja, klar, klar. Nein, also ich meine nur, dass, wenn ich jetzt so leise zum Beispiel beim Arbeiten Musik im Hintergrund laufen lasse, dann ist manchmal eine zu laut, eine Stufe und die andere ist zu leise und ich würde gern was dazwischen haben. Ich hänge genau bei meinem, bei meinen Kopfhörern hänge ich genau bei einer zwischen zwei. Das eine, das ist auch nicht normal. Ich habe die gleichen Kopfhörer und bei mir, ich habe das, ich habe auch ein Endes. Ja, die du uns nachgekauft hast. Aber dann immer drunter, wenn du dich nicht entscheiden kannst, immer den tieferen Weg. Ja, prinzipiell schon, aber manchmal denke ich so, aber jetzt gerade kommt so eine geile Stelle, die will ich eigentlich auf diesen Mittelingen. Mach ich auch. Ich mach auch für Lieder manchmal lauter, für tolle Stellen mach ich lauter. Ich hätte am liebsten so unendliche Prozent, das ist so 0,2124345 Prozent der Lautstärke oder was auch immer, dass man so quasi unendlich genau das einstellen kann. Das wäre doch perfekt. Ich glaube, es ist das Schlauste, was du jemals gesagt hast. Ohne alles gehört zu sagen, was du sagst. Ich glaube, es ist das Schlauste, was du jemals gehört hast. Ich glaube, es ist früh genug, um sich festzulegen. Bei mir ist es immer so, es gibt ja oft mehrere Instanzen an Lautstärkeabfrage. Also zum Beispiel, du hast YouTube, dann hast du im den Lautstärkeregler und dann hast du zum Beispiel noch dein System und deinen Kopfhörer. Und bei mir ist es immer so, dass die maximal weit auseinander liegen. Immer YouTube ist ganz, ganz so ein Millimeter angekratzt und Kopfhörer sind auf Maximum. Und dann gehst du einmal auf Vimeo und und du liegst auf dem Boden. Und das ist immer so komplett, ich lebe on edge einfach so. Ich bin bei YouTube dann so zwischen 1 mm und 1,1 mm ist perfekt. Das stimmt, das ist mir noch nie aufgefallen, aber das mache ich auch. Also ich meine, du kannst mir doch jetzt nicht verraten, dass du von deinem Laptop die Lautstärke, wenn du auf YouTube die Lautstärke runterregelst, die dann vom Laptop auch runterregelst. Nein, man lässt die immer auf der Lautstärke. Andersrum, wenn du was ganz leise hören willst, dann machst du die vom Rechner ganz runter und die von YouTube immer weiter hoch und guckst, wie weit du mit YouTube... Ja, zum Beispiel. Also, du hast einen Punkt. Du hast ausnahmsweise mal recht. Ja, danke. Ich muss ihm auch zustimmen, finde ich super. Du kannst damit auch besser detaillierter Lautstärke einstellen. Ich muss nur widersprechen, deine Kopfhörer reagieren simultan zu deinem Lautstärke.
Das stimmt, ja. Kommt auf die Kopfhörer an.
Ich habe noch so Kabelkopfhörer, da habe ich dann auch so einen Schober.
Wen?
Ne, du machst Schiebel.
Dein Ohr ist manchmal eingeschwetscht,
das ist das Problem. Du bildest den Lautstärke ein.
Aber du gerade Vimeo meintest.
Können wir kurz mal die Rangliste machen
der seriösesten Video-Plattformen?
Weil ich finde, YouTube ist schon cool, seriös. Vimeo ist so das Studenten-YouTube. Ja, ich denke es mir auch, ja, es ist sehr Arti-Razi, aber auf der anderen Seite gibt es auch auf Vimeo mehr so Obszönes. Es gibt auch schon Richtung Porno. Ich glaube, eben, ich glaube, die haben nicht so krasse... Richtig, ja, das ist auch so, ja. Für mich ist Vimeo sehr kritisch. Und der Quatsch ... Es gibt aber keine Pornos, es gibt aber so was, so künstlerische Arzi, so irgendwie nackte Frau tanzt auf Bühne, das kannst du halt auf YouTube nicht machen. Sehr zu empfehlen für Masturbationsnächte, die mal ein bisschen exotischer sein sollen. Gute mal ein bisschen auf Vimeo. Masturbation ohne schlechtes Gewissen, Vimeo. Das sollte der neuer ... Das Abiturientenmasturbieren. Ja, stimmt, stimmt. Oder Studentenmasturbieren. Und jetzt Achtung, Dailymotion. Wir müssen kurz... Dailymotion finde ich, das ist der Abgrund des Internets. Da sind wirklich... Da findest du Videos drauf, wo man sich fragt... Sind die auch auf... Die sind dann oft nicht auf YouTube? Ja, doch. Also ich glaube, Dailymotion ist so dieses... Ist shady. Ja, genau. Ich gucke mich auch immer um in meinem Zimmer, wenn ich auf Dailymotion bin. Hoffentlich sieht das niemand. Ach. Ich meine, es gibt ja oft so unter YouTube-Videos, oh, jetzt bin ich in dieser Ecke von YouTube gelandet oder irgendwie sowas. Live-League. Ja, ja, also sowas in die Richtung. Das war falsch, was du gesagt hast. So meinte ich das nicht. Aber ich mache, wenn ich Dailymotion nachhabe und niemand in den Raum kommt, mache ich meine Pornoseite an. Und ich... Weil ich will nicht, dass Leute sehen, dass ich auf Dailymotion bin. Das ist schon ein sehr alter Gag. Oh Gott, alles klar, okay. Entschuldigung, also Stefan, das hätte ich wirklich nicht von dir erwartet. Aber ich meine, bei Dailymotion siehst du quasi die Sachen, die du bei YouTube in dieser dunklen Ecke siehst, aber halt nur was davon. Deswegen ist dann die Frage, ob Dailymotion deswegen viel abgerufen, also das ist jetzt nur mein Erfindung, ich bin jetzt nicht so häufig auf Dailymotion. Ey, ich habe echt Angst vor der Zukunft. Vor der Wahrheit auch. Ich habe echt, ich mache mir echt ein bisschen Gedanken. Ja, wegen deiner Steuersache. Aber ich habe schon tausendmal gesagt, es ist nicht so schwierig. Du musst einfach ein bisschen was bezahlen. Vor allem, wie wir gefragt haben. Also wir sind ja steuertechnisch nüsoversiert. Und wir machen auch viele Fehler und wir kriegen auch diese Spendengelder hier. Da müssen wir auch noch drüber sprechen. Das ist ganz fragwürdig. Wir verdienen ja auch Geld mit diesem Podcast. Da haben wir noch keinen Cent bezahlt.
Du darfst es schlicht nie erwähnen.
Hör auf jetzt!
Glaubst du, dass ein Steuerprüfer guckt, dass sie... Und dann sind wir aber hier hingelaufen. Wir haben dann gefragt,
was war nochmal die Frage? Wir sind dann zu Markus, unserem Controller.
Genau, und unsere Frage war, was passiert, wenn ich keine Steuererklärung mache?
Ja, genau.
Das war unsere Frage.
Ziehen die dann das Maximale ab, von dem sie glauben, dass sie es verdienen? Weil Steuererklärung heißt ja auch, dass du die ganzen Plötungen mit einreichst, die du dann wieder zurückbekommst. Du kannst ja sagen, ich will nichts mehr zurückhaben, nehmt mir, was ihr wollt. Nehmt euch von dem, was ihr glaubt, was euch zusteht. Und die Antwort haben wir nicht verstanden von ihm. So sitzen wir heute hier. Es war Kopfschütteln und wir wurden glaube ich auch des Raumes verwiesen. Aber einmal, ich habe auch eine... Ihr kanntet die Person schon, oder? Ja, Markus. Das ist hier unser... Aber ich habe auch mal, also von den ganzen Antworten, die man auf eine wie soll ich mein Leben gestalten, was habe ich nicht verstanden, Frage nicht bekommen möchte, habe ich mal eine bekommen und zwar, du bist ja süss. Und zwar habe ich bekommen auf via-wie-Versicherung, ich bin doch über die Firma versichert, du bist ja süss. Als ich gefragt habe, bei welcher Versicherung ich bin, da dachte ich, ich bin über hier versichert, du bist ja süss. Wo ich dachte, auf den Punkt gegangen und gedacht mir, ich bin viel zu tief drin, ich habe verloren. Flash forward, er ist offensichtlich nicht mehr versichert, weil er keine Firma mehr hat. Was machst du jetzt? Naja, ich stecke mir schön meinen Anteil von den 300 Dollar hier in die Tasche. Wie teilt ihr das eigentlich auf? Also wie fair? Ich meine, Florian hat jetzt nicht so viel Input in zum Beispiel die Kommunikation zu mir gesteckt wie Stefan. Oh! Das wollte ich jetzt nur mal anbringen, also für die Aufteilung des Geldes, was ja auch... 55, 45, glaube ich. Ende 2018 fahren wir schön, schön nach Koblenz ins Casino und legen sämtliche Patreon-Einnahmen auf Rot. Das war die Idee. Sämtliche Patreon-Aufnahmen der letzten zwei Jahre, Ende 2018, alles auf Rot. Oder ihr macht ein Poll auf Twitter oder so, auf Rot oder auf Schwarz. Stimmt, dann sind sie selber schuld, was mit ihrem Deppengeld passiert.
Aber das finde ich wirklich lustig, weil, naja, das ist auch ein bisschen gemein. Ich habe letztens eine, also gestern Abend eine Idee für eine, ich glaube es war eine Idee für eine Black Mirror Folge. Die Serie kennt ihr wahrscheinlich? Ja. Ne? Ne, was ist das? Das ist so ein Indie-Projekt. Ja, schon gleich. Und zwar, die Idee war, zwei
Eltern
wollen ein Kind haben,
also nicht zwei Eltern, sondern zwei Menschen,
wollen ein Kind haben, aber können es nicht, weil sie unfruchtbar sind oder
was auch immer, und dann wollen die sich
quasi so künstlich
befruchten, hoppala, dann wollen die sich,
Popschutz, dann wollen die sich künstlich befruchten lassen,
aber können sie sich das nicht leisten, und dann
sagen die irgendwann, okay, dann machen wir jetzt halt ein Crowdfunding daraus.
Und dann crowdfunden die halt die künstliche Befruchtung und dann sagen die ja okay und der und dann sagen die ja okay, irgendwie kommt nicht so viel rein, dann sagen wir einfach, die Person, die am meisten spendet, darf den Namen des Babys bestimmen. So, und dann läuft es gut und dann spenden immer mehr und immer mehr und immer mehr und immer mehr.
Wenn Namensvorschläge kommen, dann sagen die, okay, da machen wir jetzt noch ganz viele, ganz viele andere Sachen zum Beispiel, dann macht man das halt wie ihr jetzt auch, ab 20 Dollar darfst du mitbestimmen, auf welches College der geht, und so weiter und so weiter und dass dann irgendwann das komplette Leben von so Patreon oder Crowdfunding Usern geregelt wird, das ist doch eigentlich voll die gute Idee, um an Geld zu kommen, also quasi, ich meine, Scheiße, Kinder. Nur es würde halt niemand bezahlen. Was habe ich denn davon? Eben, niemand würde was dafür zahlen. Außer man macht halt so eine Trollaktion, dass man halt die Namen sagt. Und dann finden sich schon Leute, die sagen halt irgendwie Boaty McBoatman. Kid Mac Kidface halt. Human Mac Human Face. Ich glaube, wenn man so was so Truman Show mässig dann sagen, dann läuft die ganze die Kamera, und wenn ihr so und so viel zahlt, dann fällt so ein Teil der Hammer auf ihn drauf, und keine Ahnung, dann kann man so ein Community Kind aufziehen. Und dann muss man halt bezahlen, ein Euro für ja, zwei Euro für nein zum Beispiel, und dann, nee, angenommen, das Kind fragt uns dann, das Kind fragt die Kamera, ist es dann so ein Telepräsenzroboter, der ist dann der Elternteil. Das einzige Wort, das hat er 2017 gelernt hat. Das sind diese iPads, die man auf so kleine Segways fährt. Richtig, so heißen die. Die heißen iPads, die man halt so an so einen Segway geklebt hat. Und nicht Telepräsenzroboter. Das ist das eine Wort, das man nicht benutzen sollte, weil man zu viel weist dann offensichtlich über das Thema schon. Und dann fragt das Kind so, kann ich heute Abend vielleicht bis 22 Uhr bei Lena bleiben und dann kann die Community abstimmen, ja oder nein. Also die Community erzieht das Kind. Das ist natürlich eine gute Idee. Ja, ich wollte gar nichts dazu sagen. Das finde ich cool, wenn man einfach eine Community ein Kind gibt, das zu erziehen. Klingt besser als die gesamte aktuelle Staffel Black Mirror. So, das war's auch schon wieder vom Podcast. War es das wirklich schon? Ja, vielen Dank an den 300-Dollar-Mann, der hart geschuftet hat. So wurde es übrigens knallhart in unseren Chat-Konversationen immer genannt. 300-Dollar-Mann. Du hast dich dagegen entschieden an die Kinderkrebshilfe, dagegen entschieden an die Caritas, an Amnesty International. Und hier sind sie alle. Hier ist der Flüchtlingskorps Ehrenfeld. Gegen die keinen Cent bekommen. Sondern wir kriegen es. Vielen Dank dafür, vielen Dank für dein Geld. Vielen Dank für den guten Zweck in unsere Tasche. An euch, tut mir leid, aber wir mussten das Podcast-UFO um finanzielle Zwecke ausnutzen.
Aber ich glaube, wir werden dieses Incentive jetzt auch killen.
Auf jeden Fall. Nein, du warst der Einzige, der das jemals benutzt hat.
Das war ein Fehler.
Ansonsten artet das aus.
Also ich war der Fehler.
Also du warst der Fehler.
Aber ihr seid nicht die ersten beiden Menschen in meinem Leben, die was da an die Ältesten ausnutzen.
Vielen Dank, dass du da warst. Das war Stefan Tietze und ich.
Du hast das letzte Wort.
Tschüss.
Und wir heben ab.
Wir heben ab.